[Music]
hey people this is the ruben report i'm
dave rubin
and two quick announcements before we
start first off we are here
at youtube space in playa vista playa
del rey i think clyde del rey
del rey not playa vista it's on the
border vista this is all right the point
is we're at youtube space temporarily
while
uh tyt is building out their second
studio and i'm very excited
because you know jon stewart announced
that he was uh retiring last week from
the daily show
and they came out with all these lists
these top 10 lists of who's going to
replace
jon stewart and i have number 11
jimmy dore number 12 ben mankowitz
number 13 dave rubin so let's do it here
we go all right
isis the latest isis update yeah all the
beheadings the burnings all that stuff
continues but i actually found something
that was actually kind of positive
related isis if that's actually possible
uh this grandmother this elderly woman
on the streets of syria
who started verbally assaulting some
isis members and it's really a thing of
beauty
[Music]
so this woman is absolutely fantastic
these guys are beheading people they're
shooting people in the street they're
burning people
uh alive and she is probably 80 years
old
and fearless this is this is beautiful
right
two things i thought when i saw this
video one now i know why i can't reach
my mother she's in syria
at least she's yelling at someone else
yeah uh uh and she's not 80. that woman
is easily 180 she might have been 110.
well
it's very stressful there so maybe
that's aged her a little bit more but
really this is this is an amazing thing
right no i mean once i i know how that
how that soldier probably feels one time
i had jimmy durant yelled at me
and it was really unsettling yeah and
and i gave him a kiss to build a dream
on
let's see what you did there um how do
we empower these people because every
video that we see about isis
is this horrible stuff uh we're gonna do
a segment in a second on whether we
should even be showing those videos or
whatever
uh but this thing to me was inspiring i
watched this and i was like oh there are
people there
that have the balls now she's at the
later years so maybe she's a little
uh willing to take some more risks than
you know a 16 year old she's gonna throw
her life away
exactly but really like she's got some
like this is the type this is the thing
that should have went
seriously viral i think i guess i'm
dubious of the authenticity of this
video as i am about
many of these videos because i don't
understand who shot it right
i'm confused by where the camera is and
right it appears that it was an isis
guy in the car so either maybe those
guys weren't
isis i don't know you know we don't know
we don't know this is the problem
there's really
essentially no way to authenticate also
like i mean it's good it's great yes
she's taking a stand she doesn't
they there's talking there about the
kurdish guy who they had killed and
and she's saying why you know why did
you kill him don't kill anybody so
uh it's good uh obvi if you read any of
the stories
i think a piece in was it i think in the
atlantic i might be wrong and then
another piece
over the weekend that they believe in
the end times
so they don't care like that it was a
nice explanation and there's a couple
books coming out by some serious people
not crazy fox people
about who these guys are and why they
and if they believe that well then
at least it makes some sense as to why
how how these incredibly barbaric acts
could actually be being perpetrated but
these are actually sunnis right so the
sin syria we have the same problem
because the sunnis are being like i
don't know in a sense disenfranchised
from their own
land right so we went and [ __ ] up iraq
we screwed over the sunnis
so now they don't have so all those
people who we kicked out of saddam's
army
are now that's called used to be called
al-qaeda in iraq yeah they're called
isis right so these are all bathursts
former trained by saddam which means
they're trained by the russians
which means so that's who these people
are and they're sunnis and this problem
isn't going away you can't bomb our way
out of this problem
and so that woman's right in that sense
but i don't think if
that woman would have walked up to
george washington in 1790 whatever or
74 and said stop [ __ ] killing the
british then we would have stopped
killing the british when you're in a war
you usually believe in it yeah and by
the way to talk about how crazy the
alliance alliances in our are and all
that i saw this week that we're now
going to let
some of the rebels in syria call
airstrikes with our air force
to bomb assad so we're basically the
rebels air force now so it's all just
it's just this big freaking mess so last
thought on this
um do you want to get to that point in
life where you just don't give a [ __ ]
that's what i kept thinking about that
woman
she's at that place where if my mother
my mother to bring her back to it she
got there i think at age 35.
she's been doing it for about 55 years
but really don't you want to get to that
place where
you just don't care so that these people
could literally be doing the worst
things imaginable and she has she has
more balls than anyone we know
from 1999 until the middle of 2000 i
was that woman yeah i did not care i was
super depressed i was in a major
depression
and i used to get on planes going i dare
you to fall i dare you to crash go ahead
i don't give a [ __ ]
you do me a favor so yeah i know exactly
how then what happened then i
started taking zoloft i feel okay all
right there you go
all right let's move on with isis so you
guys probably saw at least the images
perhaps the video of the 21 coptic
christians that they beheaded
on the beach it was uh i think in libya
in libya yeah it was pretty awful uh so
i don't want to get
too into the minutia of that but what i
think is interesting about this is this
debate
that we're starting to have a little bit
about the propaganda should we be
showing these videos
should we be talking about them are we
just aiding in their propaganda are we
making them
more uh more easily here's some of the
images you can see right here i mean
they just beheaded 21 of these people at
the same time
uh and then there were images of bloody
water it was pretty terrible
but basically you know are we aiding in
their propaganda when we talk about this
stuff are we somehow strengthening them
we've talked about it a little bit
before but yes
yes even what we're doing right now is
strengthening it no it's true
certainly what fox news did you know at
least if we are commenting on it
we're not forwarding their propaganda in
a sense but what fox news did when they
showed that unedited
22-minute video that they put out that
you are now providing a platform for
their propaganda yeah you are so you're
not talking about this one you're
talking about the jordanians i'm talking
about the jordanian pipes
but this is a but but you know when
chris matthews goes on msnbc and he's
like oh my god what are we going to do
we got to come together and fight this
people that's exactly what isis wants us
to do
they want us to overreach this again
this is not our problem
this is a thousand-year-old problem
between sunnis and shias
that we shouldn't be getting in the
middle of and we can't bomb our way out
of this
yeah but should we feel a little guilty
because we are the ones as you alluded
to in the last segment that
started the iraq the wrong iraq war and
thus left this case
i do i think yeah i don't think it's
easy and i think if there's a way to
to get these there's an opportunity
always an opportunity when there's guys
this crazy
because by the way i watched that video
i found it i watched it a couple things
happened when i watched it because
i wanted to see i don't know i'm a i was
a journalist i'd been if i'd been
working of course i would have seen it
and i thought i should
see it yeah it's incredibly hard to
watch i i've i'm
incredibly struck by the by the
composure
of the victims in this so i don't know
what's happening there because you there
are edits made
so but that said it is it depresses you
it is it
can ruin your entire day to watch one of
these videos i don't know that we're
furthering their propaganda because one
thing that is happening
is that as these guys keep doing things
like this
they're making enemies of our enemies
yeah and
and in that is an opportunity that maybe
there's some evidence as you mentioned
with the
uh arming the syrian was that in this
segment or the last segment
we are willing to have syrian anti-assad
rebels
orchestrate our airstrikes the this has
opened up opportunities with
iran that this is so the
the muslim world even some jihadists
are together in that hey hey hey hey hey
maybe stop cutting
people's heads off maybe stop executing
women in the street that was al qaeda
that
the video and uh and that made isis
angry
so there are opportunities here i i
don't know what you shouldn't air their
whole video i get that
but i don't know that talking about it
is is is the wrong thing to do
they want us to come they want the end
times and they want they are
they are they are saying hey come get us
come put american boots on there
yeah they want it they wanted that they
wanted something so do you see that
distinction though between talking about
it and showing the stuff because that's
that's
the part so there was the video of uh
the woman being shot that they literally
just shot another elderly woman and that
was
serious and all these people were
cheering and blah blah blah now i
tweeted the link
because to me it's like we need to
understand some of this like if this was
a world war ii i think if people had
maybe seen more images
of concentration camps or something
maybe we would have done more now again
i'm not saying we should do anything
i was against the iraq war a year ago
but to me seeing it
doesn't necessarily mean we have to do
something but we can at least have a
debate about it which i don't think
we're really doing no i
i think it's it's good in a sense if we
talk about it in the right way
meaning we don't let these videos make
us
thirsty for blood yeah don't let those
videos make us want to ramp up our war
and by the way
that woman who got shot in the street in
syria um
she was talking loud on a cell phone in
an elevator i mean
i mean at some point you have to draw a
line and i'm glad that finally they are
in syria yeah
how powerful uh do you think isis really
is because that's the other part related
to the propaganda thing yeah we see
these horrible things
i didn't watch the 21 people get
beheaded but you we see all this stuff
and then
part of me is like is to your point like
i don't want to overstate how
much power they actually have they don't
have an air force you know what i mean
like
we've killed 6 000 of them we were told
in the beginning there was 20 to 50 000
of them getting 6 000 if there's 20
000 you made a big difference so i'm
i'm for look i would be for finishing
them off
quickly if i thought that that would
work yeah you know
we just know that in that we're not we
don't seem capable of that we don't seem
capable this isn't grenada
we can't go in spend 72 hours there and
leave and high-five each other and say
look
reagan just won a war let me tell you
something else that happened that i
meant to mention
very quickly when i looked at that video
i was really worried about looking up
that video and i thought
people were going to know i looked up i
thought the same exactly that was the
first time that i thought
the people the nsa is that's a crazy
thing to think about that
that the government is watching me look
at this video and will they think that
i'm
that i like this video that i want and i
thought so i should just stop and
but i mean i don't think anybody's
really looking but it was chilling it
was chilling it affected i'm in my own
office in my home
afraid of what i'm looking up on the
computer that was a weird thing to feel
well to that point we did a story last
week that something like 63 percent of
reporters in the united states think
that the government's spying on them
so uh that's a big number that's a
pretty high number it's almost half
you might be right so i thought this
story went bizarrely under reported
because everything related to apple gets
extremely over reported but the wall
street journal reported this week that
they've got hundreds of people
working on an electric car that's right
we've got some more info for you
the car project is nicknamed titan apple
has a team of several hundred people
working on a minivan style car
that can incorporate apple's array of
technological products
if the vehicle moves forward it would
put apple in competition with the other
electric car makers including tesla
and general motors all right we know
that apple has a [ __ ] ton of money how
much money do they have they're valued
at over 700
billion dollars and they posted 18
billion in quarterly profits
uh they pretty much run everything and
more efficiently certainly than our
government
um but the first thing when i heard
about this the first thing that i
thought was oh man like i'm big on tesla
i like the idea of it i like seeing them
pop up and they're going to kill tesla
aren't they
um by the way the 700 billion is a
metric [ __ ] ton
of money okay that's a lot of money that
is in my notes here yeah i have metric
[ __ ]
um like that i might originally had that
i felt bad like tesla's doing it yeah
and now apple's just gonna come in and
i don't know i don't know i don't know
if they'll be able to beat i don't know
uh do you think you know they got a big
head start
yeah you know and tesla already has a
brand name out there that people like i
don't know that people are gonna wanna
you know cars are your phone
is instinctively this is gonna this is
me
talking marketing so ignore everything
okay but your phone
is supposed to be geeky yeah you
acknowledge that it's geeky right from
the start it's the way cool people are
like oh this is my tech thing right
cars aren't geeky cars are cool they're
designing a minivan
teslas are cool i don't think tesla is
threatened by an apple minivan so the
minivan part of it i do think is weird
but generally apple stuff isn't thought
of as geeky it's thought of as cool
right but the mini the minivan part it's
still geeky it's cool geeky
but your car is not cool geeky a car is
a
is cool and yeah the guys who drive
tesla's care about
cars what though i know that what i read
you didn't have this up there but if you
if you spin out and go sideways you get
your window in landscape view on the new
apple car
hey you see what he did there jimmy ah
that was a technological joke
um the apple minivan yeah that's what
they're building the minivan the minivan
i don't know why they're starting with
the minivan
i guess that seems a little bizarre you
know what actually i like i was once
given a minivan at a rental because they
were out of whatever it's fun yeah and i
enjoyed it
and it was it's first of all it's much
easier for kidnappings
jimmy dore driving around a minivan it's
a scary uh this true happened it was the
first time i was ever
recognized i had my first half hour
special just aired yeah
and i go i was in virginia beach and i
go to get the rental car and
the woman recognized me from my special
and she goes
you can have any car you want and i go
thanks
i'll take the minivan pulling the star
card i like the minivan um do you guys
think
to me it seems like the good part of
this even though i don't want to see
tesla go down
is that if someone if the electric car
is ever going to really happen in
america it's going to be apple right
like it's going to be apple or google
right it's not going to be gm right now
tesla well
because it's it's coming with tesla and
it is getting cheaper but like if
someone's going to really
really do it well i think gm could do it
i mean gm support they did vote if
yeah they did it so i mean but if it's
gonna but i mean i'm talking about
really
massive if it's gonna make a major dent
if 40 of people are going to be driving
electric cars if we're going to actually
reduce our carbon footprint
yeah big companies are presumably going
to get involved in this but there's room
you know there's if there's room for a
zillion uh
uh you know whatever the other kind of
car is what's the normal kind of car
gas powered vehicle internal combustion
internal that's what i was looking for
if the internal combustion car can
can have 35 companies making them i
imagine that
the apple's not going to make the only
electric car the people yeah jimmy as my
war
correspondent the war people are going
to be upset about this right because the
war people want us
to be in the middle east for oil and if
we're less dependent on oil so
they can't be happy right they are not
no they want the the march for oil to
continue for sure
so it'll continue one way or another i
think certainly it will continue
although i like the idea that that you
know again that apples
them getting involved in in electric
cars
it doesn't seem like a downside to me
yeah no i know i know it's all good i
just suddenly um i drove in one tesla i
took one
test ride with i love it and it was so
cool and it's all digital and all that
so i wanted to hang out last thought on
this how do you guys feel about apple
in general because every time we do a
story on apple people go crazy because
they either got the total fanboys
or the droid people and everything else
that just hate them and they think that
we're all
drinking the kool-aid i was a total
fanboy for a while but now that steve
jobs is gone i am not
and uh i think they're the iphone is not
on the cutting edge anymore as it used
to be
you know there's the androids have a lot
more features and it seems like the
iphone's starting to catch up
for [ __ ] which i don't like that feeling
i want to be the guy i want to be with
apple because they're
on the forefront but that you know and
then they uh they
so that's how i feel about apple they
keep [ __ ] up their programs like they
did with imovie
they did with um final cut they make it
shittier first forward i don't know why
they do that but anyway
because then the next one supposed to be
better then they go back to shitty it's
like an endless cycle
you have the giant iphone yeah plus plus
yeah uh they screwed up garageband i had
i had to disband
like my band we're not touring anymore
because that program it wasn't drugs and
women it was by the way no nobody knows
how to use the android operating system
nobody nobody in the world so okay there
you go all right let's move on
uh scientists are predicting something
pretty
uh awful a massive mega drought coming
to the united states
probably around 2050 so first we've got
a quote from the author of the study on
this
natural droughts like the 1930s dust
bowl and the current drought in the
southwest have historically lasted maybe
a decade or a little less
what these results are saying is we're
going to get a drought similar to those
events
but it's probably going to last at least
30
to 35 years now we've got a time lapse
of what they're saying that this drought
is going to look like it's pretty wide
and as you watch
brown is bad brown is bad here we go
scientists looked at two different
possibilities first
a business as usual scenario where
worldwide greenhouse gas emissions
continue on their current course
in this case the future risk of lengthy
droughts rises to 80 percent
alternatively if the world were to take
aggressive actions to reduce emissions
the models still show drying but the
trends will be less severe okay so just
to clarify what you saw there the first
time lapse was what they're predicting
and then the second time lapse is what
they're saying if we actually make a
change now no we're not huge
on science in this country as you guys
uh know if you watched last week ted
cruz
is in charge of nasa now which is a
scary proposition uh it doesn't believe
in global warming but nasa by charge of
nasa but nasa i mean the national
association of scamming americans am i
right
when you see that [ __ ] that kind of
stuff now i know we're all science
people we believe in
climate change and all that i'm not a
scientist but scientists give me
information and then i accept it
um that's scary stuff when you see that
right
yes um k why can't they come up with a
thing that cool if we can
warm the planet why can't we come up
with something that cools the planet you
know
why can't we jimmy every time it snows
rush limbaugh says see
no i mean there's got to be a way to
make the the climate more frigid i mean
can it date some of my old girlfriends
[Laughter]
am i right they needed a rim shot there
and uh
no but they actually do have the thing
where they would fly out of planes
they'd do like a chemtrail thing
yeah and they would there's a thing that
they can launch into the atmosphere that
would actually cool they don't know what
the effects you know that it's all side
effects they don't know so they they
actually do know how to cool
yeah um yeah i mean look you can walk
into any office building
in phoenix in august and it's totally
pleasant like we
have figured this out in some way right
um did you guys see interstellar by any
chance
no did you see interstellar yeah i saw
it so interesting i mean this is
basically what the premise was that we
become this giant dust bowl then we
can't produce food anymore and then we
have to go
to other planets to figure out how we
can continue
uh well that was that the the tom cruise
movie matthew mcconaughey oh
yeah yeah yeah and jessica chastain
right was she in that thing
she was in that thing too where is it
going to be raining it's going to be
raining somewhere
right isn't it i thought when the earth
heat heats up that means there's more
energy in the atmosphere which means
there's going to be more
weather events so i'm be i'm confused
how do why is it going to be droughty
here
it'd be droughty here we're talking
about the united states but this is nasa
right there there are that's our agency
it'll rain somewhere else it'll rain
somewhere else um
what makes jennifer just rain just off
the coast um
right five feet yeah that would be very
shitty but what's clear about the
what's interesting about that and the
important part is that first of all by
20
that thing ended in 2095 so in some ways
you know who gives a [ __ ] yeah right
right
um but and your children and your
children that's right i have a daughter
i forgot
um no uh is that we can do something
about it i mean
we can they you know it's not just us
that was a point of if all
sort of the you know if all the
industrialized countries
made sort of thoughtful principled
smart steps to [ __ ] climate change to
[ __ ] the warming and
and fight climate change then you get
the second scenario which is
okay yeah like which is okay yeah it's
not it's not ideal but
but it's survivable so when i was
reading this i kept thinking about one
of my favorite george carlin bits where
he says
you know people this is from years ago
before everyone was talking about
climate change the way we talk about it
now this is like 15 years ago
him talking about how the earth's been
through cooling and warming and all and
meteors have hit and all this stuff and
you know what the earth is always going
to be here
and it's egotistical of us to think that
it's all about
us but i guess we're self-interested
aren't we i mean we want to survive
the planet will always be here it
doesn't matter what we put in the oceans
whatever we're the ones we're screwing
so we're screwing up the atmosphere that
has developed that would sustain our
life
right but so we're going to screw up
that atmosphere but earth is going to be
here for us so is that the flaw of the
climate change people that they're not
focusing enough
on make they keep making the earth is
changing this is but we need to go this
is about
us then it would get people more excited
i don't think so because the reason why
people
aren't accepting the science of climate
change is because they're
being manipulated by propaganda funded
by oil
giants right so that's what this is
about yeah so is the only thing
last thought is the only thing that's
going to ever change the way we discuss
this stuff
is that when we actually have a food
scarcity like when eventually
it gets so hot that our corn because
it's going to be about corn
our corn won't grow and then that pretty
much that to me seems like the wake-up
call when americans can't get food
the way they get it now that might be
the thing i sort of see it as the
way it'll get fallout is when the people
like the koch brothers who are just
pure evil and funding evil and they're
when you talk about this that's
they're they're they're guys like them
or what and man them and those guys
themselves are what's funding this
propaganda campaign
when they recognize a way to make money
out of doing the right thing
and when there's a way for them to make
money when they see sort of green
strategies as a
as a way to get rich uh then then maybe
we'll do something you know
but or something hideous happens to
people they care about
because with so many conservatives it
only
it only affects you it's only real if it
affects you it's only when your kid is
gay oh then
maybe maybe gay marriage is okay you
know we talk about this digital
madness that we live in all the time we
never stopped looking at our phones the
second i shut off my phone i go to my
ipad the second i shot that thing i open
up my computer and then i'm watching a
screen on tv and all that
but facebook has now come out with
something that's even going to take us
deeper
into this rabbit hole they are
announcing that you can have a legacy
contact to control your facebook page
after you die that's right so
basically remembering april meyer so
this is what april meyer's page
looked like before she died and then
someone else can take
control of it uh so there's a lot of
interesting things i think this brings
up and then here you see
uh so you'll be able to pick somebody to
do it they can either respond to people
they can post things they can update
your profile picture
et cetera et cetera et cetera we've got
we've got some info real quick the
legacy contact can download an archive
of the person's photos posts and private
information but will not be able to see
their private messages that was profile
information
legacy contacts still can't delete
embarrassing photos edit posts that the
deceased wrote or delete the account
entirely
this is because being able to curate the
person's page might add
an extra emotional load to grieving so
real quick
i had a friend a good friend younger
than me who died out of nowhere in a car
accident
and over the course of a couple days
after he died that was one of the major
things
that everybody was talking about how to
get his password for his facebook page
even just to let people know that he
died then who is going to manage it all
this so this there is some
need for this as kind of creepy as it
sounds i guess
yeah i i mean i guess it doesn't seem
like a real thing
i mean it seems like a real thing people
could do it doesn't seem like i think
facebook needs to
get involved in i guess though having a
you know it's like an emergency contact
but it's like a serious emergency
the biggest the biggest emergency there
is uh that graphic you had before the
last one
it just made me think of my dad who died
and but like it reminded
me my dad died in october but one thing
that he was insistent about he didn't we
didn't know he was dying
but he was uh uh he hated the term pass
away
like nobody passes away you die you like
don't let's not
you're dead yeah uh uh so that little
sort of nuance of language was uh we
should probably avoid but i mean i guess
it's good you know
people seem to be doing it anyway you
see a lot of you know when somebody
famous
dies and you check their and i'll read
they were on twitter just the day before
and i'll check their twitter account and
still there yeah you know and i guess
this is something that
twitter would be different i suppose but
you could twitter may want to do that as
well
right so i know that uh melissa rivers
for example didn't have
joan river's password so for months they
couldn't get in i don't know what
happened that twitter wasn't helping
them then somehow they finally got in
now she's kind of promoting her own
stuff which seems a little exactly how
they lived i suppose
yeah yeah i mean they lived publicly and
you know you get they everybody gets to
make their own
they every family gets to make their own
decision and you know
i don't know joan rivers personally but
don't you suspect that joan would have
said
melissa if you can promote your own
stuff from my twitter page after i'm
gone
right go go go actually the greatest
honor
jimmy what do you make of this thing i
just want to know what happened to april
why did she die she was so young
she was so young she had such her whole
life ahead of us don't think you should
make jokes i think
you're looking at you should be worrying
about what facebook if you could appoint
a legacy contact for when your career
dies
there you go we should actually stop the
recording and do that right now
i'll be yours i'll get our senior halls
guy
um so the perverse part of this does
seem to me that we can't stop with all
this technology stuff right we keep
talking about it we know people are
spying on us all this other stuff
and yet now we're even worried about
after death what does that say about
human like we never want to let go of
what we got here huh
yeah i couldn't give a [ __ ] of what
happened to my facebook page after i die
yeah yeah you just don't care just could
not care less
i don't think i'm gonna care about
anything when i'm dead but what about
don't you want the jimmy dore fans
for you to be i don't i don't give what
my fans do
my leg it's all [ __ ] that's all
eagle while you're alive when you're
dead you don't have an ego anymore
you just have a soul so you don't give a
[ __ ] yeah all right there we go jimmy
dore believes in souls i can't believe
it what do you think uh are you gonna
have a legacy contact when you're
dead and you're you want to keep your
facebook page going let us know in the
comments right now
researchers at yale university did a
cognitive study on 300 dogs and they
found out that almost
in all circumstances dogs pretty much
act like
humans so it's a huge huge study which i
don't want to get into all of it but
there is a link right down below if you
want to see the exact study and what
they did
and there's also a local news story
that'll kind of sum it up for you
um i have no what what happened
jimmy stole my pen jimmy stole your pen
just like a dog would steal a bone
i like that you acted it out a little
bit um so yeah so it's really
interesting it doesn't surprise me we're
all dog owners
it doesn't surprise me that dogs behave
the way
people behave does it uh does it shock
you brownie acts just like jimmy dore
doesn't he
well the problem is like i resisted
getting a kindle for so long
and i got one and now my dog has it all
the time he loves it
he's uh he's reading a dog's life and um
mostly a lot of porn yeah yeah yeah but
um
dogs don't have great attention spans
either which i think you're proving is
i i think that dogs have human emotion
that's what that study's saying that
dogs dogs basically react to things so
they did a bunch of things
where they would hide things and they
found out that dogs would go about
finding things the same way humans would
use the same
senses dogs didn't like it when uh the
they're human which i hate first of all
this is a yale study so all those dogs
think they're smarter than all these
yeah
but uh that like if i read it correctly
was that the
the you'd be reading a book and then
that you'd put the book down your dog
would see you put the book down and then
someone
another person would come in and take
the book and the dogs didn't like that
that your book was taken so really yeah
so the dog would get defensive
and then would be barking at people and
things like that i mean we look a lot of
this i think is
inherent it's just um like i've said
evolution with dogs right
let's uh let's clear something up though
i have i have three dogs
sort of now i feel like i'll always have
three dogs and no and this is just true
it's painful for people to hear
take the dumbest person you've ever met
in your entire life
yeah and they are smarter than the
smartest this is not true it's a hundred
percent
that it's not it is a hundred percent
are we all thinking of the same person
one person just popped into it i know
lots of people who are dumber than dogs
nope
and and you you know
a dog you're you're talking like a
mentally handicapped person the dog is
dumber than a mentally ill i think you
were going on the main spectrum yeah
i'm i i'm not singling any type of
person out i wasn't trying to
but you're saying a dumb person you're
just a regular
working dumper see like a dolphin or a
whale or a dog
they maybe they don't they can't they
don't have the gift of language they
don't have that part of the brain
but they have other parts of their brain
that are more developed than ours
that are actually smarter in certain
ways than us so we might weigh
well i think they can distinguish smells
better than we do
they can distinguish facial uh
perceptions better than we do so they
so they're smarter in a lot of ways that
way plus you know you ever see a
well-trained dog
they're much smarter than a lot of
people i know right so i'm not uh
don't you ever come home from a rough
day at work or something bad happen in
your first life or something and your
dog can sense it now i know that doesn't
necessarily mean smarts because that
could just be they they're responding
no no it could be a chemical dogs can
smell cancer they can tell you when you
have cancer they're smarter than doctors
there's like six dogs that can do that
no they can do that they can you could
one of them dialed 9-1-1
once ever my dog does that so he talked
about piss him off and go
what was that i go what nothing i
thought i smelled cancer
[Laughter]
do you guys think you love your dogs in
a deeper way
than maybe some people that you know
maybe even some family members like i
love my dog so much i took her i was
telling you guys before we started
she had her teeth cleaned yesterday so
they had to you know put her under and
really from like 9 00 a.m they have to
be put
under to brush their teeth they're
geniuses
and i said she wouldn't bite but they
didn't trust me they want to do it
anyway but really from like 9 a.m
to like 5 00 p.m the whole day i was
like ah what you know it's one in a
hundred thousand that don't wake up from
the anesthesia
and i was freaking out all day long and
even now it's a day later and she's
still a little loopy
but i was thinking how much i love this
animal has given me so much comfort and
joy
more than i love some people that are
pretty close to me i think they put me
under to get a colonoscopy
okay so you don't have to be smart to
get a stick stuffed
i think brush your teeth a little more
complicated than sticking this wand up
your ass
yes i love my dog and it's amazing that
you know dogs also have emotions you
know i had a sister who tried to tell me
that they don't have emotions all
instinct so you don't have to that's not
true dogs certainly have emotions right
and they're they're uh they're emotional
beings my dog could sense when i was
depressed and needed his my old daughter
yeah that's what i mean
and he would come over and comfort me
when i was standing in a corner crying
not knowing what to do with my life and
he knew and so
there's a certain intelligence i yes i
and i bet the thing is too
dogs never do anything to really piss me
off like they never
they never reveal a secret you told them
they never try to [ __ ] your girlfriend
they never steal money from you they
never tried to
they never make fun of you or denigrate
your good work
so i never started legal awards how do
you not say that that's your they'd
never do that
but i always said that's what makes you
love them more there's always just
positive
things coming from your dog that's i
love my dog certainly more than a lot of
bring us home do you love your dog more
than you love some people that are
everybody told me including dog owners
including one of my best friends who's a
dog owner and he said
you know when you have a child as i now
my my kid is almost two
you'll it will change how you feel about
your dogs you'll still love them
but he was wrong it hasn't in any way it
hasn't
you know you're the second person i've
heard say that so i still i mean don't
get me wrong
if i have there's a fire and i can only
choose one in a fake scenario like
like the terrorism ticking time bomb
thing do you torture somebody
uh you know i'd save my daughter but i
love i don't
bob is uh i i love bob
almost as much as if there's a ticking
tom bomb and there's a dog in sam harris
i'm taking the dog
[Laughter]
thank god sam harris is a deeply
spiritual person
sidebar to all of this is a couple weeks
ago i had a dream that i lost
my dog and that ben mankowitz found my
dog and brought
her back to me and i told ben that and
he literally got white in the face this
is totally true
and you said to me that just the day
before you found a stray dog on the
street and
brought it back to their owners so there
is something deep with
what do you think uh let us know in the
comment section right below so i saw
this in the daily mail
and i know a lot of people get crazy
when we do stories from the daily mail
but i think every now and again they
sort of hit on something that's
culturally interesting they did a story
on the rich kids of instagram
basically these kids that are worth
millions sometimes multi-million dollars
is that a real thing
what this is a real thing a real thing
that's what i couldn't quite tell if
it's like
the daily mail called the rich kids of
instagram or is there like a group
that considers themselves the rich kids
so i think from what i could tell i
think it's a little bit of both like
they're referring to themselves as the
rich kids of instagram
there was one of these groups in iran
too and that one got shut down by the
government pretty quick
uh so let's look at a bunch of images
these are the rich kids of instagram
uh so titled by themselves and by uh by
the daily mail
and basically it's these kids that are
just super duper rich and they're kids
they're in their teens
early twenties this is not their money
that they earned this is money given to
them by their parents and they're in
planes
and in boats and they're in exotic
places and
wads of cash jimmy do you have those
kinds of 100 stacks 100
bills on your gold under your gold watch
and they're in these crazy hot tubs and
pools
and i thought the story was interesting
because we all see this every time you
go on instagram you see someone's food
looks better than yours every time
they're at a beach
because of the filters it looks better
than the beach that you're at and we're
all making ourselves kind of crazy but i
think there's something particularly
kind of gross about it being kids that
didn't earn the money
himself unearned confidence is repulsive
horribly republican really is repulsive
it's okay
to be wealthy like you don't have to be
ashamed of inheriting your parents money
little ashamed you don't have to be but
not enough to not take it
how did you say unearned unearned
confidence oh so that's why we
don't like luke russert so much yes yes
that's right yes
that's right people like just be
appreciative like
you know so go on instagram and do what
everybody else does and show a picture
of you with your friends
instagram there's too many photos of
ourselves
no kidding there's just it's it's it's
it's
that's a like we did a story earlier
that'll be up on the ruben report about
the
legacy contacts on facebook and jimmy
made a great point like yeah you're dead
it doesn't
nothing matters doesn't it and you know
there was a way that we were able to
inform people that you were dead before
facebook i'm pretty sure we can go back
to that right it gets out
you know um so and not everybody needs
to know right away that i died
it's okay yeah like you know people will
be if people find out in nine months
oh i ben didn't come on he did oh that's
that's a shame let's have a drink to him
that would be nice that's okay
that's all i require people have to go
on with their lives so this it's just
embarrassing to look at these kids it's
embarrassing and they don't know it
they have george w bush's unearned
confidence and it's um
so speaking of the under archives i got
a quote here from one of the girls that
does this stuff that posts all this
stuff
i thought it goes exactly to what you're
saying she says i don't think i should
be judged for posting a photo
like eating caviar at clarity's in
london while it's okay for someone to
post a picture at mcdonald's
so she's saying well i'm just doing the
same [ __ ] i just happen to have more
money so i'm doing it nicer
no that was that's what's called being
out of touch
yeah what she just said she doesn't
understand what the problem is yeah
because she's out of touch she's like
that person
so badly needs therapy like they might
be able to she could be a functioning
normal person of course there's a
difference
yeah but by the way who cares about you
with a picture of mcdonald's by the way
right not necessary yeah i mean go to
mcdonald's it's fine nobody needs a
photo i'm pretty sure
that the french fries at mcdonald's are
probably better than the french fries at
clarice
i've never been to clara just i don't
even know what it is caviar declare just
you know the expression about that
they used for george w bush i don't know
who said it first but and maybe it's a
hundred years old or it's as old as
baseball but it's the best expression
there is
you know these kids were born on third
base and think they hit a triple yeah
you can't put it any better than that i
think it was i said that or ann richards
it was either you or anne richardson and
richard richards said that and then she
also said poor george bush born with a
silver foot in his mouth
exactly right well that's they're both
good and that that does sound like ann
richards
do you agree with ben's point that have
we ever been more vain
than we are now as a society because no
selfie sticks all this stuff
i think we're just as vain we just now
have an outlet probably which is
i think it actually makes us vayner it
makes us all constantly thinking about
how we look and appear
and you know they've done studies they
figured out that people who spend the
more time you spend on social
media the more depressed you are and the
reason
is that they posit i agree with it is
that people don't post their failures
people only post when they're winning
look i'm hey look i got invited to a
comedy festival in hawaii
hey look i'm doing a new movie i'm on a
set hey look at i just won a million
dollars in vegas hey look i'm doing
so nobody ever goes hey i woke up today
wanting to kill myself again here's a
picture you know one of the best
one of my best attributes jimmy is that
is that
um i'm a bad self-promoter like
and there's something there's a quality
to that that i'm uncomfortable promoting
myself
right and now on twitter that's what and
about twitter
i don't really go on facebook i don't go
on instagram it's just twitter and
mostly what i do on twitter is read
get information articles people send so
i think i use twitter for the right way
but that said
you're supposed to go on twitter you're
supposed to promote yourself you're
supposed to be
and and and now i'm getting more
comfortable with it and it sucks
it's too bad it has taken away a quality
of mind that now i'm a little more
comfortable
talking about how great i am and i'm not
that great i'm just like everybody else
yeah and i hear you on that and i
look i'm a big twitterer i'm all over
twitter all the time and i try to keep
people entertained while also promoting
stuff
but also there there is something you're
trying to entertain on twitter once in a
blue moon
again someone tweets me back and says i
don't get that i'll look again
but but there is a difference for the
way we have to use it right for
the way we have to use this stuff but
yeah but sort of it's part of what we do
if you were doing all your gigs and just
wasn't on facebook or twitter it would
be stupid yeah yeah
yeah so no you have to do it and by the
way i just
uh now instead of me blocking people i
try to get them to block me
very nice so so yes i can imagine that's
that hard yesterday
oh you believe so yesterday i went out
and there was a comedian in the midwest
and he put a picture of him he has a
picture of himself with victoria jackson
from saturday night live yeah oh yeah
and he's right he made a big thing but
she's crazy right so he made a thing
about how
she was they didn't want her on the show
the 40-year anniversary and she had to
they she had to sit in a room by herself
it sounds like she got her own dressing
room that's what it sounds like for me
and he said it was because she was a
conservative christian and i i kept
praying no it's because she's [ __ ]
batshit crazy
and says a lot of hateful stuff about
people and i would link to an article
the 20 worst things that victoria
jackson had ever said and he would
immediately delete it and i would
immediately put it back up and he would
immediately and i started putting on
other posts on his page and putting it
everywhere
finally he blocked me nice job you need
more to do
with your daily activities all right
what do you think's worse the rich kids
of instagram or the uh
poor average people of twitter let us
know in the comments right down below
all right so i love doing these stories
on food and how we eat in america how we
source our food how we get our food how
we treat the animals how we treat the
farmers all that
so sweet green in schools is a new
initiative
and what they basically did is they took
sort of the average school
lunch that they're getting in nine
different countries including the united
states and they compared them
so we're going to roll through some
images here first up is the united
states and uh
so those are chicken nuggets yeah and
some frozen peas
and a cookie and mashed potatoes which
actually look pretty good and a fruit
cocktail
all right so that's not that doesn't
look terrible right just like that it
looks
does that look does that look pretty
terrible there's no fiber on that dish
around that plate except maybe a little
bit in the peas right so that
fruit is all sugar syrup that's right
sugar sugar that's actually dessert
yeah so that's a tutor there's two
desserts yeah i was actually saying not
that terrible just because there was
something green because you see so many
of these imagers they're not now i guess
the reagan administration said
ketchup was a vegetable there's a
vegetable all right so we're just going
to keep rolling through these things
look at grease a nice greek salad that's
nice some orzo
like baked chicken yeah looks like greek
yogurt wrapped something
this is south korea oh look at those
greens and the vegetables
little chopped dog brazil brazil
there's less meat on the brazil uh plate
than i would have thought but it looks
like there's a meat
uh finland again they got the sweet
potatoes or whatever that is and they
got
like a green soup and the beets and that
looks horrible but it's healthy
whatever that is there that looks good
italy we knew italy was gonna be good it
looks like a nice fish
fish they're giving the kids fish and
salad and some grapes
yeah i mean look at that uh spain look
at those shrimp 999.
somebody's gazpacho got spotted that's a
cold tomato soup by the way yeah uh
ukraine even the ukraine that looks all
right there's something going on
look at france look at that piece of
beef wow they don't get that big of a
piece at a restaurant in france that
looks horrible that piece of beef is
scary
eat that with a gun i'd rather go to the
ukraine and give up my meal to a russian
soldier who's not there yeah uh all
right so those those are the nine that
they looked at now i know what
a lot of you in the comments are going
to say but these aren't what average
like they're just picking
what the supposed ingredients are they
probably look like those weren't real
lunches
well i think those were those are sort
of the average lunches all right the
average idea of it they're probably
don't put them on plates that literally
they put them on right they made them a
little more they probably instagramed it
and filtered and all that stuff
um but is it no surprise to you that the
us is the worst
i mean not questions at all yeah yeah
yeah we eat incredibly poorly and uh
we start eating incredibly poorly you
know it's really hard now i mean i'm
trying to
feed my two-year-old you know what's
funny about my kid's going to turn two
next month which means that right now
you know we say 23 months but she's one
like until you're two you're one and so
i'm like you know i get mad at her i'm
like josie you picked that up and i'm
like
she's one who yells at a one-year-old
yeah so
but then you're but that's something you
still haven't uh but you can get out of
here
kids like it's hard to get him to eat
well but you got to train it
early that it's okay to eat broccoli
because i don't want i do not want my
daughter
eating like me i don't i like that you
said train it
well we did a story before about loving
your dogs and he's
training his child like a dog i'm very
appreciative
that you said uh drain it train it why
can't we get food right in this country
every time we do one of these stories
we're always
the worst we're always the worst because
we have no food culture in america right
so americans were a bunch of
pilgrims and [ __ ] that didn't know how
to cook and they had to ask the indians
how to make corn
and so that's what it is you know italy
they have their own culture of food
you know japan they have their own
culture of food america our culture of
food is [ __ ] cheetos
and mcdonald's right we don't really
have a culture of food
right and i think that's why but as a
melting pot nation shouldn't we now
now that we have so many immigrants from
all over the world what are they saying
white people are going to be the
minority
by the time we're done with the show
because the corporate structure here and
we learned how to make food incredibly
tasty and incredibly cheap
and incredibly accessible and it turned
out it was incredibly unhealthy but that
didn't stop people from making that food
because it was too profitable and
they're still making that right
and it was driven by the desire for a
profit margin and they figured it out
in the 1950s and then it expanded and
grown it
and we all fall victim to it i mean i i
drove home last night from a movie i saw
a hot tub time machine too
i'm sorry bragging jesus um and uh
and i stopped at a kfc and got one of
those chicken pot pies that i saw
advertised because literally if you
advertise something on television
in front of me i will go buy it
you're a good consumer and it was
delicious
oh yeah it was so good but how did you
feel after because for me when i go to
these places i don't
know yeah you did yeah you did really
the chicken pot pie somehow because
there's like
you know it's bad for you because it's
like just this thick cream sauce but
there are
you're like oh i just ate a carrot
yesterday i went to
this place called beer garden in
pasadena for their burger and they put
it on hawaiian rolls
oh yeah hawaiian roast oh they're so
sweet
oh they are they're so good anyway i'll
stop talking
people are talking about this butter
burger that jack-in-the-box i haven't
gotten yet
what's the butter burger it's what you
think it is it's a burger cooked in
butter and then a bun that has butter on
it and it tastes fantastic
yeah well if you're gonna do butter
people if i know one thing do the
grass-fed butter i like kerrygold
uh what do you think are you on the
grass-fed butter are you using coconut
oil i love coconut oil let us know in
the comments right down below and don't
forget to
subscribe i'm going to start by asking
my panelists a question here would you
say you're more like a bird
a cat or a dog dog dog dog dog
i also would have said dog the reason
i'm asking them this question is because
sex
stamps are the new thing that are
happening at sex parties
and you put a stamp on you uh which
basically says what sort of sexual
stuff you're into what you're okay with
people approaching you with if you what
is it
mine the world yeah sex parties
sex parties that's what the young thing
ben the young people are having sex
parties we've got more info for you what
so yeah here's what the sex stamps look
like so you can get a bird you get a dog
you can get a cat and you can put them
all over your body so that when you're
at one of these sex parties
the people basically can decide what
they're going to do if you need to be
given consent before they do something
or if you don't want consent or if you
want a little rougher or whatever it is
so here's some more info for you
the second base makeout party is part of
a communicative
consensual movement helping to create
more structure in the world of intimate
often sexual parties because of the
slightly taboo nature of these parties
and the range of interests
they indulge in consent is an evolving
tool in ensuring safe fun
and attracting new participants i am not
interested in helping
or offering my opinion on uh people who
go to sex parties like this is not a
thing
that is happening all right well you've
been able to believe it 57 kids have
gone to a sex party
they should be very careful and people
should be treated respectfully
this is not a thing that's happening in
america it's never happened it certainly
didn't happen
between in the 1980s i'll tell you that
right now somebody
somebody never got invited to a sex
party have you been have you gone to a
sex
a sex party i don't think a sex party
where people were just having sex with
never no of course not because there's
never been one
jimmy never been one jimmy you were a
comedian that started in the late 80s
there were sex parties
first of all i still think there's a
chance i might be president so i'm not
answering
president of what of anything yeah i
have
been to quasi-sex parties uh but what's
with the new the stamp
so they put a tattoo so if you so one of
them the bird means you want to be left
off
you know you really want to be uh don't
approach that person they'll approach
you they all have
different meanings so that you know a
dog
has to be a little more aggressive this
way 99.97
have never been invited to a sex party
have never heard of a sex party
and are mortified that their child all
right you old man who never got invited
to a sex party i've got a little more
info on these parties
uh at this makeout party those who say
they are dogs here we go for the
specific info for you
okay uh indicate that they are open to
being approached and touched
cats must be asked before things are
initiated birds are the most selective
in choosing
and do not welcome direct advances but
animals are free to evolve so you could
have two and people can figure out
anyway if you have haven't you know just
stay away from that guy yeah do not get
involved you've done anything else
orangutan because he'll hurl [ __ ] at you
um
do you think this takes the fun out like
we live in such an over i got it i got
it i got it
we live in such like over-regulated like
nobody wants to offend them
take the fun out of a sex party yeah you
don't even believe sex parties exist
i was over i was totally regular at a
sex party
you know i was going to invite you guys
over for a sex party this weekend and
now
i'm not inviting you anymore you've
mocked the second you want to come i
would love i'm
coming of course all right i give
up sex parties are you having them are
you having group sex right now
do you got a bird or a dog or a cat on
you let us know in the comments right
down below
and on that note i want to thank jimmy
dork who will be at my sex party this
weekend
you know what i'm going to let you come
you can watch how about that
ben menquitz who will watch the sex
party guys
for watching subscribe and we'll see you
door we'll see you now
[Music]